all right
evan bliss alan sakin what's up my
brother here we are
so happy to be here i'm so happy that
you were such an important foundational
piece to
simulation landing wow in los
angeles so thank you it was a joy man
you you came around
just around the time i could really use
somebody like you in my life
so the the uh the gratitude is mutual
wow so honored yeah our tennis has been
on fire great word for it yeah yeah our
dialectics been gold evan's definitely
been helping augment
my world view in really important ways
so
also that feeling's mutual
the reason why this episode is titled
cannabis
architecture is because you have
in the last two years
you've built up an incredible design and
architecture
background and then you you saw
an emerging market that's right
this is so fascinating a lot of us
don't watch the macro level patterns
emerging
of the market that's coming and then
you see it and then there's this big
hole that needs to be filled because
there's
all of these extraction and distillation
and growth facilities for the
emerging cannabis market that need the
proper architecture and design
protocols that's right absolutely and
this was beautiful that you saw that and
now
it was funny while i was at evans in
this foundational transition
to uh los
angeles what happened was i got to see
firsthand
i got to go to a facility with you
that's right which was less so don't
forget that that's which was so cool i
went to a facility with evan
and i saw him in action doing his
high level uh execution of making sure
that all of the proper architecture
protocols are in place because there's a
lot of
unique things in the code of law that
have to be in place to make sure the
facilities are safe
and all this type of stuff which will
unpack and also it was cool
there were a lot of people calling evan
a lot of people
call evan it's true that want to get the
highest level insight into how to
properly
structure their extraction distillation
build facilities
so he was getting a lot of people that
were just calling in that have a lot of
money
that are that are that are building
that's that part
and and that evan is is consulting them
they're relying on
evan to be able to have that high level
view so
i love this that's why the episode's
titled this we're going to unpack this
in detail and actually evan even has
some great uh software that he's going
to show us
of how he actually architects the um
the cannabis facilities as well so we'll
get into that
let's let's unpack that kind of
transition
from having this uh evan and i for those
that
want to see also i think we talk about
this in the first episode when we talk
about the ethos of architecture that's
right
we have this is round two technically
with evan and i think we mentioned in
that episode but evan and i went to high
school together at roosevelt high school
in sioux fall south dakota
and evan was a senior when i was a
freshman
and we met i think an orchestra first
was yeah the first place definitely
that we met evan was playing violin
with bill robles uh you're one of your
other very close friends very good
friends yeah
and alan was a freshman playing
the viola and it was fun because these
guys were
uh seniors it was a lot of fun but
that's so we've known each other
uh 10 now 10 plus 10 plus yeah years
we're
approaching 15 technically because i was
14 when i came to
high school i'm almost 20 now
approaching 29 so it's crazy wild stuff
so evan got to go to um the university
of lincoln in nebraska for architecture
and then to the university of illinois
for masters and then straight out to la
for five years you've been in la doing
work five
close to six yeah probably close to six
so
walk us through the and you've been
designing really cool stuff in that
first episode you can see we embedded a
bunch of the really cool things evan has
designed in the past you can watch that
episode and see it but
let's talk about the transition into
cannabis architecture
you let's do that yeah thanks thanks for
that great intro alan that was uh
that's one of your strong points man i
feel like you i gotta bring you with me
everywhere and you'll just
give me the beautiful intellectual red
carpet um
so i i agree let's talk about
transitions i think
what there is to talk about here is both
the transition from the type of work i'm
doing
and also the way in which i'm doing it
from a
employee versus employer versus
entrepreneur status too right i mean
really my transition from doing
architecture proper
traditional architecture you know houses
offices
multi-family residential um
i've done a little bit of everything
medical medical even offices as well
my transitioned in type of work
coincided with my transition to becoming
a true full entrepreneur right
truly self-employed you know
backs always against the wall to some
degree i mean definitely thankfully at
this point about
two years in there's some momentum but
that last time we spoke
i was kind of on that cusp i hadn't
fully made that leap yet i was kind of
my toe was in
i was starting to get these these
cannabis projects and i could feel the
momentum ramping up and
it was clear that this this this had
some potential
but i couldn't quite see yet where it
was going to lead to so
um bless the transition to
entrepreneurial
you know i think we've spent enough time
together i think we both kind of
understand that idea that
probably either of us we just we just
couldn't hack it any other way we kind
of got to be our own
got to be in our own lane right and i
think we're probably better for it and
perhaps
the people we deliver our service and
our intellectual ip and our words to
i think they're better served by us
being you know
independent creators right so yeah
boy it also boils down to a lot of it is
the
classic rich dad poor dad that's right
robert kiyosaki
really at the end of the day we have to
make sure everybody
is inclusively steak held so that we're
all
generating wealth and ownership and
not just selling our time for money
so that's right it's very important to
be a shareholder
in uh wealth engines like
brands and businesses uh and
common stock of companies and real
estate
and make sure to include things like the
environment
in as an inclusive stakeholder the
seventh generation indigenous principle
right that type of stuff so all right
um can we go ahead if we riff on that a
little bit i i know that
that's the thing with you and i alan too
i think we've covered such a tapestry of
ideas
in the time that we've spent together in
the last few weeks that it's hard not to
want to grab
some of those points and pull them out
right and
on a quick footnote to what you're
saying um
that kind of mentality of owning your
your enterprise and owning
the creative work that you make and and
also being entitled to
the value generation that's created as a
result of that that's something that
really
came into my purview about a year ago
and
it was something once i realized it
because i never really had any formal
training in business so that wasn't
really a
kind of north star that i thought about
this idea of vertical integration
ownership of the the full supply chain
of whatever
physical intellectual property you
deliver right um
because in architecture really the way
it works traditionally is we're really
just a consultant
along the supply chain if you will along
the process of delivering a building
and what i you know in some ways i was
introduced to this idea of of
getting more of the process into your
court by listening to hip-hop because
that's really something
if you look at hip-hop in the last like
10 to 20 years that's kind of
that's kind of the de facto this is what
success looks like is when you own your
masters when you own
the um company that makes your t-shirts
you know you have a clothing line you
have a
vertically integrated brand an image
that that you know
it creates a full monetization system
around your art
and i i would say part of what i do is
is grounded in that principle and that's
really
i think the next step for me will be
furthering that even more
i'm in some sense i'm kind of stage one
entrepreneur where
i own this system i own this kind of
organization i'm in but
there's still outside parties right like
it it's a client still comes to me
um so i still have to wait for somebody
to knock on my door in some sense
thankfully right now there's lots of
knocks happening but you know lo and
behold
the world is the way it is and maybe one
day there won't be as many knocks so
i'm trying to figure out how can i take
some of those cues from hip-hop from
tech from the business community about
how do i kind of create my own business
by
being both a instead of just a
consultant
a an originator of the content if that
makes sense
yeah and i'm
so bullish on
certain emerging markets yeah one of
them is
the cannabis and hemp markets as you
should be
absolutely and we just talked about this
also in our
simulation los angeles video that we
just published a couple days ago as well
is that
i'm also someone asked me about my
thoughts on bitcoin decentralization
i'm also very bullish on
decentralization technologies and
cryptocurrencies very bullish on that
and so
in a sense we can on a macro level see
these as emerging markets
that are massive
wealth engines for civilization they are
and in order for us to properly
inclusively stakehold everyone as
they become these massive fruits
is going to be critical to make sure
that we don't just continue the
extreme bifurcation of inequality
but rather that we aim to have everyone
get wealthy
you're together uh in a way that kind of
biomimics
nature a little bit more closely
so all right let's um let's sort of
see where we're gonna head here with
um these first steps i would maybe want
us to do something along the lines of
like
i am have identified now
we've talked about this on the show
quite a bit but that there's basically
different
codes of law in different countries so
countries are basically like little uh
combinatorics
of codes of law and so the united states
has a very
friendly code of law to entrepreneurs
that's right and so
a lot of people are really excited
that's actually probably the number one
thing about the usa that's like better
than everything is
the entrepreneurial code of law so a lot
of people
don't realize that and they should
definitely
think about it more because they can
make a wealth engine for themselves that
way
but so it's different for example for a
country that has legalized cannabis
in south america versus europe versus
africa over
asia versus north america you're gonna
have
different laws and so now you also in
the u.s have to do another
combinatorial split between the 50
states that's right
yeah yeah so evans worked everywhere
from up and down the coast of california
all the way out to maine
yep on the far side on the east so all
these different states have different
combinatorics of laws that enable the
emerging cannabis market to flourish so
you're you have to basically also
analyze
codes of law across the states that's
right and then
have the basically the building
codes that architectural codes that
for all of the different i mean you're
going to walk us through this but just
the last week when i went with you you
know you guys were like we're going to
have to put up
a dozen of these massive
what were they called on the roof those
were those would be uh condensers
and those weighed like 600 sensors
or something four to four to six hundred
pounds somewhere in that range and so
yeah
basically if you're gonna put twelve
four to six hundred pound condensers on
the roof
you really need uh strong
i was looking this up the trusses you
know the trusses
and you have to be able to distribute
the weight
from those points so that that's right
there's safety
so walk us through what it's like seeing
all the different
combinatorics of like the united states
cannabis emerging and working in the
different markets but also
kind of fielding in the calls from the
clients about we want to do this i think
you were telling me that
extraction is the vast majority right
now of your
cannabis architecting work is that's
that's right okay so walk us through
this yeah well i i want to riff on um i
actually think maybe a good intro to
this
is talking about the difference between
states because i think what's happening
with the
cannabis legalization rollout in the u.s
is a great case study
in the states as laboratories of
democracy right and laboratories of
different
iterations of structuring laws around
different ideas you know i mean that's i
think that was a fundamental idea that
the founding fathers had right you know
there's this idea of a connection a
federal government that's kind of this
umbrella
that has certain laws in place that
extend in every direction for every
state
and then kind of utilizing each state as
a way to test
different ways of running their local
governments right and that's happening
in a really real way with cannabis right
because
it's this completely new frontier um
it was rolled out in a couple states you
know early on and they have become
in some ways the definers of how all
these other states will interpret
everything from you know the licensure
process for
folks to get a license to be a business
in the space
um definitely in my in kind of my domain
and my territory the way that
each building department will look at
code reviews
for you know cannabis related facilities
so california washington colorado
they're the pioneers right and and
obviously for me i know the most about
how california's approached it and i
still think in some sense they're kind
of the market leader
um they're i mean i've heard stories
about
you know small city and in trying to
think somewhere that
has legal cannabis that's kind of just
coming up
um you know somebody in a small city in
michigan they'll call
the city of sacramento they'll call um
oakland and they got to get the run down
on
how somebody's these plans just showed
up for this cannabis facility
what in god's name is this like we don't
even really know how to evaluate this
it's so new it it has some precedent you
know i mean there's there's
other biological cultivation facilities
where you might grow flowers you might
grow tomatoes there's other forms of
industrial production where you're
making distillates um
you know buy what would you say
botanical
extracts i mean you can extract the
scents from flowers you can extract
essential oils from
um other plants so it's not as though
there's there's no precedent for this
stuff but it's
it's it's to use your word it's in the
nuances where
things get get uh spicier i like what
you said about
how it's as though there's
people from michigan that are
seeing the emerging market of the
cannabis architecting occurring
and there they have to do
mimesis as rene gerard would say of
sacramento yeah i love that that's so
cool
well it's interesting too because they
need to say
it happens on multiple levels because
there are codes on the books that just
are what they are
right so to go into a little bit
of a technical direction um generally
speaking in the united states
the state building codes are are
generally based off what they call the
ibc
the international building codes so
they're just they'll take that codified
book of
i forget how many chapters but and then
they'll they'll add certain amendments
uh per state that you know have to do
with there might be particulars of
the climate in that area or something
some other modification that
you could justify for that region but
once you kind of know
generally how to navigate through the
ibc international building code
it means i can pull up the florida
building code the california building
code
and and at least kind of know what up
from down right
so there's those rules but then there's
also kind of
there's the interpretation level right
of the hermeneutics
yeah i mean how do you application you
know i mean and
every building department's gonna focus
on different things that's funny
even though there's the interpretations
you'll still have the fire marshall
visiting
exactly right i mean it's just yeah yeah
it's not it's not it's it's an art and a
science as much as we would
yeah yeah to me the arts kind of the
political part where
you know what kind of
the thing i noticed frankly is is does
this jurisdiction want
a cannabis project in their city
and there's someone and that's where the
political spin can come right like they
can
how much are they trying to catalyze it
that's a great way to put it and some
are really gung-ho
i mean especially the ones that
understand the emerging market because
the more that you understand it the more
you realize it's a wealth creation
engine for your city yeah couldn't put
it more concisely and and i'm seeing
that a lot actually in my more recent
projects here in california
a lot of these kind of desert cities
that don't necessarily have
a well-established industry anymore
that would love the cash flow the the
tax
dollar influx of a really high growth
industry so they're kind of accepting
the cannabis in hemp industry with with
open arms
you know i'm desert hot springs at
alonto is where i have multiple projects
i mean they're
they're all for it they're all for it i
mean it's great for their tax base it
gives people jobs
i mean and i mean frankly i think most
of this
these this product you can feel good
about because
i with the risk of going too much
left field i mean i i think we all kind
of understand at this point that there
are some clear
benefits health-wise to this product to
cannabis and
cbd right so i i don't think it's it's
maybe a little bit different than the
way you would think about
another liquor store or bar opening in
your town i think there's just
there's an edge to that i think we we
understand alcohol has a certain
um socially questionable
impact in some cases um i can i can hit
the spectrum
because we've had at the new west summit
which you came to which is which was
awesome
we've partnered with them the last two
years to do partnership interviews
through
the world's leading cannabis tech
conference on one side
you have people that we've we got to
interview on the program there
um where you have these rare clusters
of diseases where you're literally only
um one out of a couple dozen people on
the entire planet that have this
and that there's nothing that traveling
from hopping around the world
to different world-renowned physicians
trying to
make sure you don't die at the age of
like 16.
um and the only thing that helped out
after all the world physicians
tried everything and couldn't figure it
out was a massive dose
of hemp cbd uh daily and so
all of a sudden the rare cluster of
diseases went away
you know hair is growing back um yeah
the
the super hardcore pain in the arthritis
type things in the hands up for like 16
year olds is gone
on one side of the spectrum on the other
side of spectrum you have all the
recreational use of cannabis and so
if you're striving to be an entrepreneur
but you're waking up every day at you
know 9 00 a.m and awaken baking and then
you're
and then you're also smoking in the
afternoon at two
um you know are you you know the
question ask yourself is is that are you
really catalyzing your
entrepreneurial success by doing that
and so
there's these two sides of the spectrum
and then an alcohol is the same thing
you and i are very familiar with the
balmer peak with alcohol
yeah yep so you can fascinating to me
yep you can micro dose
alcohol to a very small extent to where
you're
actually decrease your uh your
inhibition yeah your anxieties for
socialization
um we've heard of many people that have
successfully attained
a world renowned breakthroughs in fields
like mathematics under a little bit of
alcohol things like that
yeah and i like the side of the spectrum
is where
you said um the other side of spectrum
on alcohol is where
you're going to the bar you're having
six drinks
um you're you're getting a blackout
intoxicated you're
doing one night stands you're um
and that's a that's a whole uh you might
be more
have a higher proclivity to be violent
um there's all of these drinking and
driving
very very vigilant with that
yeah so on a side note on the
cannabis conversation that's a very
important um point
but you're right that you're gonna have
places that are constantly
trying to either you know
if you're hyper conservative and you
absolutely don't want
um the advancement of the emerging
market you're gonna
you're actually missing out on what
could be a multi-million
if not approaching tens of million or
hundreds of millions of dollars
for your city plus all of the not just
money but also the
inclusive stakeholding like we talked
about the medicinal benefits
um on a recreational side there's also
potentially
an uptick in creative strategy that can
occur from small doses so
there's a lot of things that spur up the
the these cities for ones that can try
and become more open
to the new emerging market coming coming
absolutely um and i think
yeah i mean part of the reason why i
think it was worth going down this
tangent we went
just did is because it kind of
solidifies something i know you and i
both agree on and that is that
we must be ethical in business and we
must be ethical
in the things that we create by our
business right and
i think no matter how lucrative being in
cannabis is if
you're doing it right you know if you
kind of happen to catch a wave in it and
perhaps get the right contacts the right
opportunities i it's such a wave but
you know at the end of the day if i
didn't really believe on a very
fundamental level that this
wasn't that this was a positive product
if i if i even had some degree of
reservation like
it would be tough right to really have
this be such a core part of my design
business if it wasn't really something i
believed in
and i know some people can suspend that
but it meant your ethos yeah you know
what i mean i
i definitely want to make the case for
that and i think most people
that are cannabis or cannabis adjacent
feel similarly like they
you kind of have to buy yeah you kind of
have to buy in right you have to say
i'm gonna we can steer the ship towards
the more positive light
direction yes the positive light
direction it as a therapeutic as a
positive life enhancer and it also has
something we think
is going to have a net benefit for
humanity if i think for most people
they're
i don't you'll find the occasional
person who's clearly you know they're
just kind of
it sounded like a gold rusher it sounded
like a cash cow so they jumped in they
didn't really
vet the ethics for themselves personally
but
yeah i think it's an important step and
the same thing happened with the
emerging
decentralization and cryptocurrency
market since satoshi nakamoto's white
paper in 2008
you had a massive gold rush since
approximately
2016-ish where people got involved
without any sort of foundational ethos
and that's the core thing is you join
into the emerging market
with the recognition that you are
steering the ethos of that emerging
market
and you and you're trying to do it
towards
positive light benevolence inclusive
stakeholding love that kind of stuff
this is and this is something that we'll
probably get into on
in our next conversation on um more of
the philosophical things but if you
start
with the spirituality the morality the
ethics
the enlightenment if you start with
trying to channel
christ buddha confucius lauts of the
gods of the world if you try and
channel them and start with that
everything downstream that you touch
business-wise entrepreneurship-wise
science-wise
friendships uh relationships um
children everything you touch downstream
if you keep in mind that first principle
of trying to keep the highest possible
morality and spirituality
the other things downstream um unfold
well
so we can we'll chat on that
more in our next conversation i agree
do you do you think that um
within the i always like to ask in terms
of power law in
like so in cannabis architecting we have
this power law
and so we're going to say that you know
what is the most
you know the phone calls that you're
getting most what is the protocols that
most people
want you to architect in cannabis so
it's
you know extraction yeah this type of
stuff right
okay yeah well i could in some ways i
have yet to be just really clear about
what i'm doing
let's do it so here it is so
so my company now i would say 90 of the
work i do
and you know i'm trained as an i studied
architecture i have an undergrad degree
in architecture a master's in
architecture
practiced at various architecture firms
five to six years so i have you know
deep domain expertise in that
but really what we've become is almost a
cannabis
specialty design company and with it
with a really
exceptional focus on extraction and
what extraction is is it's it's
so i think usually when you say cannabis
industrial production people are
thinking grow up right
they're thinking a greenhouse where
you're growing the plants which is
typically referred to as cultivation so
that's one thing
and definitely here in california that's
i mean
prior to the legal market existing i
mean that was already very robust and
like just people growing cannabis right
and the emerald triangle exactly that's
right yeah that's right and i've done
some work up there but
you know when it became legal both
recreationally and medicinally
um the first move business owners went
into was growing
right so just like any industry when
it's fresh
and it's new like there's those
opportunities at the beginning to be the
first mover and really capture
large market share which i think
happened but
somewhere around and and granted i i
haven't i'm not somebody who's been in
cannabis for 10 years so i can't really
i can't tell the story with that depth
of knowledge but i will say that
i know in the last two to three to
perhaps even
four years there's been this kind of
shift to people rushing into
the extraction space because cultivation
has been so saturated so
what's powerful yeah that that that's it
what's what's powerful about extraction
is it's
so it's the saturation of the
cultivation space
that created the forcing function for
people to want to get into
the extraction space that's super
interesting i mean
in some sense in some sense alan um
cannabis flower is just another
commodity right
it's it's in some sense it's no
different than corn right i mean corn
corn isn't highly differentiated there
isn't you know between brand a
and brand b there's you know
near imperceptible arguably difference
it's it's
it's a commodity by economic standards
and
and cannabis in some sense is becoming
that too i mean not to say that they're
of course there's kind of boutique or
or bespoke or you know very specific
genetics that are
charge a premium price and have special
branding behind it but in terms of the
typical
flower product that that market's kind
of flattened out in some sense as a
commodity
so you know the solution to that is that
you have to innovate right and
though i wouldn't necessarily call
extraction and innovation because it's
that ideas existed for a long time it's
existed as
probably ancient you know it it really
originates with hash right which is a
purified form of cannabis from the
middle east
um but the way it's done in a modern
context is um
very simple you're you're purchasing
what they call biomass which is bulk
kind of usually kind of the leftover
materials typically
probably a lower concentration of thc or
cbd or another cannabinoid than you
would find in the flower that would be
produced
for direct consumption so there's this
kind of there is a i suppose an
economical argument there
you're you're you're creating a valuable
product out of something that perhaps
would have been
in some sense waste or is not as
valuable so
what you're doing is you're you're
taking that in in the kind of the most
basic sense
the process works this way you're you're
putting it in a centrifuge
with with super chilled solvents
which are you know butane ethanol
pentane um
what else do we have i mean it a number
of different solvents and what and you
whip that very fast
in this centrifuge kind of it's like
frankly like a washing machine like
imagine putting
green organic materials in a washing
machine with solvent you know it's kind
of a bizarre thing you wouldn't see this
in any other context
these are big washing machines they
potentially are
yeah some of them get very large but
yeah we're talking like garbage bags
full of biomass like containers
full of biomass that are like you know
huge like the size of a human body
and stuff like that like these are
there's a lot of biomass yeah
yeah yeah but what you're doing is
you're you're creating
you know you're whipping that around and
you're you're you're extracting
the solvent is kind of pulling out those
cannabinoids right
and then once you've ran that process
you're running a series of purification
distillation
operations on it to make you know as
pure of a
end product as possible and then that
oil so
so we in the centrifuge you have the
solvent connecting
with the cannabinoids and then as
they're extracting out the cannabinoids
from the biomass yeah
then that process undergoes a
distillation
where you have to extract all of the
solvent
out and keep only the cannabinoids
in the final product so it's
hyper-concentrated cannabinoids
well that's the other part they call
that solvent recovery is that process
where they
you know essentially pull that all out
so you don't end up with the product
that
i mean perhaps you know and it's
something like parts per
million or billion it's something really
high where you can't have
more than a certain threshold of solving
right trace amounts true solvent
remaining um
and and i will i will say for sure i'm
when it comes down to the nitty-gritty
of the process
um i i wouldn't be the first person to
i'm not as well versed on that
facilities planning
permitting code as it relates to these
machines is really where my
expertise at this point lies i mean
there's definitely people that
could give you a much more yes
comprehensive level of
you know if you're actually a lab
technician there every day
doing the thing you know there's there's
a really nitty gritty version of it but
from a high level what i just described
is effectively it but
and so then and then walk us into the
next so the centrifuge
so now is there usually something that
the
the clients inquiring with your process
that they ask about what
the architecture designer has to do for
that first
sort of uh you can like envision it as a
modular component of the actual
extraction facility is that centrifuge
so like what do you have to prepare for
that as an architect and designer first
and then i guess we can go to the next
modules yeah yeah
yeah so i mean i have um
even though in some sense my individual
company in the scope of putting them on
a floor plan
you know based off our knowledge of how
process flow works with
use of the equipment based off our
knowledge of fire protection design
um and just kind of laying out you know
where where do the parts and pieces go
um okay and then interesting yeah so
so after the the centrifuge section
the you there's so there's the
architecting designing of that component
of the floor plan
and then there's the next components of
the distillation and removing the
solvent there's these components and
it's very in a sense there's these
condensers on the roof
and like so you have to make sure that
you know so i guess one of the first
things is the floor plan
yeah do we want to do the visual now
like the software would that be good
timing or do you want to
what would it be good to show the
software and the visuals how about when
we transition
at the end of this little bit and then
to the booth then i think we can pull it
up sounds good
um because
my the bulk of my work and it starts
when we've
ended the kind of schematic design where
we've proper
drawings and specifications that we need
that i include
in my package of goods that i submit to
cities it's it really comes down to them
having the right things for me the right
raw materials and information
so that they can produce their work so
so okay so
just that like envisioning i'm
coordinating the dance yes
so there's this yeah there's the
conductor
and that as evan as the center node that
is
uh taking the the client's desire
for the distillation facility
and then evan's connected to other nodes
that
do the plumbing
electrical mechanical and they have to
so you guys kind of go and do
site visits and you have they feed you
the their data packages about the
entirety of the floor plan design and
then you plug it into
your you as the center node that feeds
the data and the final
design to the city yeah okay
and then the city then is like okay
everything is here
so we're not going to be worried about
like
catastrophic issues occurring so because
of that the city approves
and then the process of the formation
uh towards the distillation facility can
actually be
prop uh executed so then that's really
kind of the core
of you as the orchestrator node and then
the
conductor node and then the other
members of the orchestra that
symphony that help put together that
package that then goes to the city that
they
confirm for the cannabis architecture to
actually
yeah okay okay and i think it it in that
way of working
definitely i think suits you know to go
on a mild tangent as well that
that way of working to what areas
require
with extraction what areas require
explosion-proof environments because
when you're doing this stuff with
solvent man when you're whipping
solvent around and and cannabis around
inside this giant washing machine
you know there's vapors that can make
their way out into space and
you know if there's a high enough
concentration in the area that any spark
goes off you know
imagine one of these lights or somebody
flips a light switch or their phone gets
a notification and the circuit
goes off i mean it could send something
up right so that's really kind of where
the rubber meets the road for me
and how i was able to start doing more
of this was understanding
what this explosion-proof environments
side of the design
was wow okay so
okay so one of the main keys of
distillation facility architecting
is explosion proof um explosion
management
in of specifically uh
ensuring that there's no oh my gosh
like tiny leakages of of
of solvent that can then get sparked and
explode so then is that the booth
that's right okay that's right okay so
basically so
perhaps this might be the right right to
just let's spin around a little model i
think absolutely
you know i mean i think it's fun to
listen to somebody talk about this we're
about to get the visuals
we're all visual right
is a valuable thing yeah okay
we're here all right so
now you guys should have a
now first let's start with what is the
name of the software is this autodesk
uh so autodesk is a manufacturer and
they're they're they've been around for
30 plus years they're kind of the gold
standard for
architecture engineering software
autocad was their first
product you know that kind of changed
the world of drafting and
design but this particular software is
uh revit
which this is a revit it's product
that's right okay revit
yeah and revit is probably maybe
it's got to be about 15 years old
somewhere in that range 15 to maybe even
coming up on more now
but it was kind of a it was the next
leap forward so
without going too much into detail i
think are actually our last conversation
our last talk together we spoke a little
bit about this
software in particular but what revit
has over something like cad
is it's 3d modeling number one so you're
not just looking
and imagining something as lines on
paper it's actually volumes it's
actually things in space
but it's even beyond just 3d modeling
it's
in some 3d softwares when you model a
sphere
that sphere doesn't have any properties
or any
materiality or any meaning to it until
you assign meaning
but in revit it's what they call
building information modeling
meaning that you're almost kind of
building more like a kit of parts
where when you draw a wall or when you
model a wall
it actually is a wall and you can select
you know is this a
cmu block wall that has you know that's
eight inches thick
that has um you know some sort of
reinforcement behind it is it a
a gypsum light metal framed interior
partition
that has you know r13 insulation inside
it like it
it'll automatically default to some of
those properties and those properties
can also be tweaked
so it it there's so there's a higher
concentration of
data yeah in the component parts and
that you can embed in revit versus the
more generic cad yeah and and it just
there's
there's some efficiencies that occur
there because it used to be with cad
when you would draw one drawing you had
to
all that information that you placed on
that drawing you had to represent
if you're doing it cutting a section
vertically and looking at the building
vertically all those
notes and all that information that you
apply to that
that has to be re-represented when you
do another drawing that shows the
building from another angle or another
cut
whereas revit um you embed that
information so when i cut
something differently show a different
view a lot of that's already just fed in
it's already there yeah so it's just an
incredible efficiency
yeah yeah i love the benefit of
advancements in software those
that's for simplicity of creativity and
fire codes and
uh all this type of stuff is super
important it's just an enabler it's an
enabler yeah yeah
all right let's see and we could go down
there's other rabbit holes i could go
with revit but yeah perhaps
let's see what's going on with this all
right so um
so what we have here i mean i think in
some ways this is a great
archetypical representation of these
cannabis projects i do because kind of
what you can see right away
is that this is just a big big big
open empty space
this i mean this warehouse gosh i'm
trying to think how big is it again
this is the hundred thousand square foot
one or is this no
no this probably i mean fifty
maybe let's say maybe it's about fifty
maybe fifty thousand
don't quote me on that ish but um wow
we're doing a portion we're doing a
portion of this space and turning it
into
an extraction operation so so those so
those um
on the left right now where it looks
like those doors are opening those are
the uh
the metal booths that's those are those
modules
of where it's doing the safety
explosion management is in those well in
this particular instance actually those
um so the client already had shipping
containers inside they're just using
these for
processing rooms for work rooms okay
okay so
th these things these long skinny guys
that you're seeing here in this case
actually aren't the boost but they look
very similar
so but in terms of a typical project
this is usually how it works out like
client comes to me uh they've got a big
you know they've got a warehouse big or
a small
empty warehouse and they want to build
out a laboratory facility
so it's in in our industry what they
would call
a tenant improvement meaning that it's a
raw tenant space and then we're
improving
you know we're building things inside to
improve the functionality improve
bring it up to an occupiable space so
yes yes um
this particular project is i would say
on the bigger side i mean there's a lot
of these
things that we're building inside as
compared to some where we might just
even build
you know one or two rooms but
yeah what are the different components
you're building inside can you can you
run that around us through that yeah so
in some cases
in some cases some of this is not
terribly different than what you would
find
in any other industrial or office
project
um we're just you know we're kind of
building box rooms inside
um so these rooms right here are
actually just built
out of typical uh gypsum
studs and framing okay um so it's just
what you would see you know the typical
drywall that you would find in a house
and
an office any kind of normal space that
just white flat
um it's got light metal framing under it
so just typical studs
and then a gypsum ceiling
and that's kind of just the work rooms
okay those serve as the spaces where you
don't have
classified equipment that needs
explosion proof
got it treatment environment okay um
so that's just where we're doing things
that don't have that volatile aspect to
them
and then where are the spaces that have
that volatile aspect to them yeah in
this case they
are these uh they are these bigger boxes
over here
and oh yep yep okay i see i see
and so what i'm gonna do is show another
3d view where i can kind of cut away at
these a little more
uh okay cool cool so
the way that i approach doing these
projects as well
from a architectural and a documentation
standpoint
is that even though bim has this aspect
where you can
in theory model everything we kind of
model the essentials and then hack the
rest in the drawings and what i mean by
that is
like there's a level of detail that we
create in 3d that
at least creates the framework for where
everything's at and
you know where all the equipment's at
how high the ceilings are how high the
roofs are where the structure is but
what we'll do is we'll cut away
different views and then we'll annotate
those views with more detail
so what i'll show you after we cut away
in one of these boosts is i'll show you
um actually like a drawing sheet where
we show
the actual construction details of one
of these booths inside so
okay um but to just kind of give you an
idea
this if we cut into one of these booths
here
oh i see you're giving us the interior
so right now of those explosion proof
booths yeah so both these guys here both
these booths here
both boosts here are um built of 18
well one is built of 18 gauge steel the
other 18 gauge
steel actually actually relatively light
it's actually not not terribly thick wow
um
18 gauge steel very easy to ship out and
assemble on site
um and in theory kind of what these
boots are is they're almost like giant
spray boosts right like if you've ever
done spray painting and you've you know
it's kind of like a table that has
a ventilation mechanism at the top that
sucks up
you know all the overspray right because
you don't want to be huff and paint
paint
while you're you know painting your
crafts your
your coffee table or whatever you don't
want to be huffing solvent in this case
and so definitely not
and so that's being so then these have
a a component to them that takes
and sucks out the solvency
potentially air out of them and brings
in fresh air
both exactly okay exactly so it's it's
it's
i'll answer that question first i like
that question so okay the the
fundamental way that this operates
is it is
this big box and then it's got these
little boxes
on the end right these kind of like this
part right here
right where we've created this cavity
we've created this cavity
um that's referred to as a plenum um in
mechanical engineering and you have that
on both sides right you have this plenum
which is just a gap
between the outside wall of the booth
and this inside wall
okay and what's happening there is
that's a place for air
to be sucked in or to be spit out so
what's going on as this booth would be
built is that you have
on top of this box you've got two fans
one on one above this plenum and then
one
above the other plenum and what these
fans do is they
essentially create continuous
ventilation in a linear way
long ways across the booth so
okay during typical operation those fans
are usually going to
run at um a fan speed
they call 15 500 cfm 500 cfm
uh which is kind of a you know a
moderate speed but it's enough that
it keeps fresh air coming in
continuously and
what's going on is those fans are ducted
directly to the outside
so which they have to be you know we
have to have a way to get fresh air
into this this you know this box where
all this
wacky stuff is happening with solvents
and where there's the potential
for this gases to build up in the air
you got you got to kind of keep a
continuous flow
but what happens in what they call a
purge instance
so in the case that there's a detector
inside this and in the case that that
detector senses
that there's
an inordinately high concentration of
solvent butane ethanol
in the air you know parts per million or
there's different metrics by which you
would measure that but if the detector
sees that or it it it detects that then
it will kick on those fans to a high
speed typically
1500 2000 cfm interesting so it's
dynamically adjusting
based on the ppm potentially of
the solvent in the air its speed is
being adjusted to that
so you have what would be like an
outflow of air
and an inflow of air going into the
exactly
it's just continuing continuously
cycling through so then these have to be
very
these have to be placed close to the
exteriors
of buildings then typically um so
you can do it two ways to provide that
ventilation you can either
uh in this case of this project because
the ceiling is so high we're taking the
ducts out the side
of the exterior wall um okay and
this i think this will could potentially
help you understand a little better
this is what they call a section drawing
in architecture which is
you know if you were to cut just take a
cut down
vertically through the building and then
just look into it you know like straight
on
dead on you end up with this kind of
imaginary cool cool theoretical view
right
so what we're seeing here is a cut
through those extraction booths
and like i was saying there's data here
that we've added that's not modeled in
3d
like these ducks right i'm only showing
them in 2d in this instance
and the fans as well and i'm showing
them kind of schematically
um but from here you can get an idea of
how that concept works right you have
the fan that's mounted
directly on top of the booth um it's
just going to suck
it's going to suck the air up into it on
one side um
and then it's going to bring fresh air
in on the other fan
on the opposite end right so that you'll
get that continuous airflow
using fresh outside air and just to be
just to be
um clear this is the
kind of number one most
important aspect to
your work in uh cannabis
architecting especially distillation
facilities especially
the explosion safety is that correct is
this kind of like
yes sir this is where definitely where
to use the kind of a cliche this is
definitely where the rubber meets the
road with these this is kind of the core
element
like everything else with the design of
these facilities flows around that
like interesting oh yeah okay
so this is really the hub that the
basically the city wants to make sure
that this
you nailed it okay is up to par
yeah and this is where i really had to
nail down and double down and become an
expert in
how this works and what codes i need to
be conscious of
to make sure that we're designing this
space that we're documenting this space
in a way that shows all those critical
metrics that
the city is going to look for because
what this is i i don't think i've
actually said the term yet this is what
they call a class one
division one um hazardous material
environment
class one is highest is that highest
class or
it is yeah class one there's classes
yeah and then there's divisions
and those are you know they go down i
believe through three there's
there's one through three in class and
then one through three in division
this is class one division one yeah okay
so this is
very sensitive environment so it needs
to be the precision level with the codes
need to be very high the city is really
looking at this to make sure you've
nailed it
yeah that's right um and
they want to make sure that everything
inside this
is explosion proof because that's
that's what really certifies a space a
c1d one class one division one is that
every
electrical component inside is spark
proof
right spark proof electrical components
inside
like we spoke about earlier you know i
was kind of saying the phone like what
if you get a notification and then it
triggers a spark and then it sends
everything up right so do you have to
buy
specific uh electrical equipment that is
spark proof
you do you do okay so here's where we
can kind of go into the innovation and
and and so like i said before this is a
team effort this isn't
i'm just a part of this puzzle you know
i have my own company that specializes
specifically in taking
that kind of initial design you know
where are the parts and pieces where'd
all the machines go
you know what boost do we need how much
how big do we need the boost to be to
fit all the machines
source explosion proof um outlets on the
wall for
any equipment you got to plug in in this
thing wow and so
you got to get that right right you got
to nail every component of this
you know it's got to be certified it's
got to meet the engineering standards
and then you have to document that well
enough in your plans and in your
engineering reports
that you can communicate that to a
jurisdiction that would be approving it
so trust me i mean there's a lot of
potential pitfalls along that journey if
you're going to try to build your own
one of these right
yeah so where the innovation comes in
c1d1labs the company that makes these
boosts
they said hey why not make a turnkey
solution
why are we reinventing the wheel every
time why can't we just have a product
that we ship out and it's got everything
right it's got it's got the exit signs
that are explosion proof
it's got the switches it's got the
electrical it's got the
18 inch explosion proof fans that can
accommodate
the 500 cfm up to 15 or 20
to 2000 cfm it has the control panel
that coordinates and
all those components together so that
when the gas detector triggers
it knows to increase the fan speed right
yeah so interesting it's a turnkey
solution turnkey solution
c1d1 labs that's right that's super nice
i give a pitch
i will give a definitely give a plug to
them they deserve a plug
yeah that's a hell yeah it'd be fun to
bring on uh someone that
is uh one of the founders or something
like that onto the show
i talk to him very frequently that'd be
a lot of fun because that's
that's an interesting way to
like you said if like 20 years ago or
whatever you had
so many people going and trying to
individually source the different
uh electrical components that were
explosion proof
and that would just be a nightmare to
now be able to go to c1d1 labs
and to say i'm building a distillation
facility and then it's just like
click and drag and drop basically and
well in the best case scenario
yeah i'm not going to pretend that i
mean and the thing is there is a gap
in like i said where i kind of come in
is that gap between okay we've got the
booth
and we've got the explosion-proof
components like this unit of what we've
got
but how does that fit into and connect
to everything else infrastructurally
totally that's right that's kind of my
domain
it's like when you do click and drag
before you drop you have to work with
the architect and designers
to make sure that uh when you do drop
that everything is going to be flawless
in yeah
because otherwise the city just won't
approve it anyway it's kind of like
i would say in some ways it's kind of
like dropping if you're if you're into
computers i used to do that stuff when i
was
a teenager but if you've ever built your
own computer it's like when you drop the
processor into the motherboard right
so what i'm doing is the motherboard
circuit layout and then this
this booth is is the boom the processor
the
green technology yeah great analogy yeah
so it's it's funny because architects
are then like
a motherboard and then the components
um are like the c1d1 labs and
all the other components that you drop
in
so that's super that's a that's an
interesting analogy
um we'll probably talk about this more
in the
more philosophical uh second convo but
um i love how what c1d1 labs did
is very much so like what you were
teaching me about
the you know i love the 90 of all world
trade happens by sea
in barges but that um
before the innovation that was made by
what was the gentleman's name do you
remember
i have it written down but his but he um
he did the the systematizing of when it
used to take
people an entire day to unload
boats when they when they docked or when
it would take people a whole day to load
boats rather than that
the actual shipping containers that go
on barges
that are the rectangular ones that have
very special special safety locks and
latches
on them so that they can stack um which
now you can
you can use those massive cranes at sea
ports
that enable the barges to be
just super quickly unloaded loaded
um whereas it used to take so much
longer and now same thing c1 d1 labs
and then you know you work with
architect designer to make that happen
actually
this sort of modularity is ex or
just like we were talking about with
motherboards as well the modularity
philosophy is huge even in first
robotics with the kids that
build robots to complete objectives on
playing fields that imc
and and and judge and and game announced
for
they do a very similar process with
modules inside of their robots that have
to fit into very specific
um size restrictions like if it was
going to get shipped off as a rover onto
mars or whatever
um and i think actually you know
apple for their devices also has to have
the you know this modularity com it's
such a famous example
of like putting together the module
it's a great thing for entrepreneurs to
think about is like how can you
how can you modularize
uh and then become king or queen
of the modularization of a component
um and then that way you fit into peter
thiel's philosophy as well where you're
basically the only one
doing the competition is for losers
that's right i
love i'm such a believer in that and too
and
if we do if it's okay i think we should
just do the philosophical side if that's
okay i want i have so much to say about
what you just said let's do it
and and to just to go a little bit more
on the peter teal quote there
that's really where when i look back on
how i've
cause nobody because nobody's doing the
cannabis architecting yeah there you go
and that's kind of what i and for me was
kind of a simple calculation
i guess i didn't really tell too much of
the story how i ended up kind of doing
this and how i built a business
that is so focused on this but some of
it was serendipity
like i i just happened to kind of get an
opportunity to be involved with one of
these projects
and just saw something in it and maybe
some of it was just the fun about
learning is something i
didn't know much about and just really
deep diving and becoming
somebody that was really well versed in
it like that was a thrilling thing to do
but
i think on an intuitive level too i saw
hey man like
if i'm ever gonna hack it as my own uh
designer and have my own design company
it's going to be tough if i do one of
the traditional things if i do
if i'm just doing houses i'm just doing
offices commercial because trust me
alan i've worked i've actually had the
opportunity for especially those markets
are saturated
they are and i've actually worked for
you know somebody who's probably one of
the great
great office designers of the last 20
years and then like you know the reality
is is
sometimes david go goes up against
goliath
and wins but it's kind of one it's
not most days right so how can i how can
i do
be intuitive and smart and strategic and
savvy about
how i approach this by picking a niche
that nobody's mining yet or very few are
mining yet
and that's what immediately resonated
with me you know and it's been enough of
a way that i could actually build
something right
you know yes that and that loops us also
to the very beginning
of the episode where we talked about the
emerging market of cannabis
and to sort of see
what nobody else is doing and
be able to fill that niche at the
highest
level so that you basically become the
cannabis architecting monopoly
until and you become the goliath for a
while until
maybe at some point some david can come
in and also try and innovate that kind
of forces you to also see what they're
doing
because a lot of younger consciousness
is really interesting there i agree
they're entering into the space but you
really have to have that macro level
view
um like you're discussing and to
because you wanted to be an entrepreneur
and you wanted to
not be in the houses and offices
space and it's i enjoy designing those
types of buildings i'm definitely not
saying that i don't like those things
and enjoy them it's just a matter of
what was going to be the fuel that made
this rocket ship take off are you going
to get the dozens of phone calls right
away
there it is yeah and you get the dozens
of phone calls right away with what you
decide you nailed it yeah
and then this can act as an engine for
all the other things that you're saying
gateway drug
yeah it's the game gateway it is the
gateway for sure
this is your gateway a lot of
entrepreneurs when they talk about
wanting to do entrepreneur becoming an
entrepreneur
as cuban says it's really important
to find your gateway that's right and
if if you have to
scan the landscape of the markets
to find your niche and your gateway in
um and then once you kind of become that
peter thiel monopoly of the space
and you saturate it with your brilliance
and creativity and hyper
demand of all the people that are just
like oh i'm popping up in michigan
and he calls his homie in california and
the homie in california is like yo i've
worked with
studio bliss you've got to work with
them yeah and that's
that's that's ultimately what will also
fuel all of your other downstream
desires in um north star
potentials and you know some of those
we've talked about some of them yeah
and i think at the end of the day the
problem we solve for clients is
we help remove some of the uncertainty
in this process the
the issue and the reason why we've been
so robust is that
your average person who's doing
you know construction drawings for these
projects or you know working with mep
teams and engineers they just don't know
most just don't know anything about this
project
these project types the only way you
would maybe know a little bit about this
is if if you were a classically trained
engineer would be
if you'd worked in like petroleum
engineering or
you know design petroleum facilities
because there's some of these standards
that are
playing out there you know for reasons
you can imagine solvents you know
hazardous materials
explosives yes interesting so
only like petroleum uh engineers or like
refinery engineers would
they would know about you know about the
fleas yeah yeah because even in like
whatever aerospace or automotive
manufacturing there's not really these
like
explosion proof maybe there's some with
motors and jets and stuff like that but
yeah
yeah but i mean it it it and i think any
good business solves
a solves a problem right it that's at
its core that's what we have to do is
solve a problem for somebody
and i think why this works so well is
it's very clear what the problem is
and we give a very clear solution the
problem is
you have this very specific set of codes
and very specific type of facility
we're trying to create your average
designer engineer throws their hands up
or has to spend hours researching to
figure the hell out how this works
and they might even get it right 0.9
have one no
and that's why you fill the points one
percent yeah
that nails it and let's remove the
uncertainty like these people are
already spending
generally large sums of money to build
these facilities trust me i mean some of
these
pieces of equipment themselves are a
hundred grand you know just for one
and that's only one piece of equipment
in the process so
these are not yeah i mean we're talking
sometimes millions and millions of
dollars to build one of these facilities
so
you know you don't want to be risking
uh you don't want to be taking too much
risk with how you execute this you know
you want somebody who knows
yes knows a roadmap so um
would you say that there's other
critical components that you want to
show on the
software before maybe we um well
i think without with without the risk of
just going too
hyper specific and technical which i
think we could certainly do with this
um but i i think i think what we got
what we needed from this
i think in terms of just um explaining
what's going on here in terms of the
c1d1 aspect
in terms of these pieces of equipment i
think maybe taking a peek at some of
these
that are modeled in here like this this
i think just to put a visual just
because we talked about it so
specifically earlier
this is what uh what they call a
centrifuge right so this
it's kind of exactly what you would
imagine it's this uh it's got this
you know vessel on top that uh you
you put the cannabis in and you put the
solvent you're piping the chilled hyper
chilled solvent into
um and then you've got this motor on the
right side here that's gonna spin this
thing really really really
fast um that's the motor on the right
that's exactly interesting
and it's not shown here in this
particular little 3d model but there's
you know a control panel where you not
terribly different than a washing
machine where you set the speed and
those sorts of things
um okay but uh so that gives
i think that gives you an idea um cool
you think that's good on software on
showing the architecture and
design layouts and stuff i could show
you a little more about
documentation i mean uh
these drawing sets like i was saying
about the bim
aspect what we're doing is modeling the
major 3d components
and then in each one of these sheets
that we're creating that are part of the
drawing set for the cities and for the
contractors
we're taking cuts through those 3d
modeled components and then drawing
additional information over them
so i think probably most of your
your viewers know what a floor plan is i
think we all know what that is and
here you know we have these series of
different annotations on top of the
floor plan that are telling you about
um aha yeah you know where annotation
component is really what the city also
wants to see as well
yeah i mean they want to know beyond
just where the walls
you know what is this wall constructed
of how is it attached to the floor
you know where are these electrical
outlets
uh definitely in this case uh the
critical notes like this that tell you
about
what c1 d1 components um
are what their requirements are and
where they are required to be
so this note about uh boosts our class
one division one areas right
um oh sure yep there's
all these notes here with the numbers
which are what we call keynotes which
you know that's standard for all
architecture projects
and those all tagged to here on the
right side so it's just a list so
you know you you kind of file through
and you see the one the two the three
and you can go over here
and read about what is being called out
there you know
in some case here it was
fix up the floor you know notes for the
contractor fill any cracks refinish with
epoxy
those sorts of things but um
yeah without going too i mean we could
do a whole episode for sure on just
architectural documentation
but yeah yeah it's it's um
i think that's enough intro too
excellent excellent okay
wow um i was gonna say as you were going
through that
um you know what was what was really
interesting that came up for me
was this sort of idea that
it's probably the other person that
understands probably as much as you do
is probably the guy at the city that's
right
that gets these high ups
or a girl whoever the city gets the
files yeah
and and and in some ways we kind of feed
them information
to so one of the other people on the
team that i
work with on an ongoing basis you know
the outside company
all the consultants there's a fire
protection engineer that writes a report
that essentially describes the process
that's occurring
in this facility it describes how you
know line by line how does each
component meet the fire fire codes
you know that's its own thing i'm not
really i'm not really touching much in
regard to the fire protection aspect
of it that's really in his camp but that
but that report is a critical
element of the submission because the
plan reviewer at the city can read
through it
and immediately understand what's being
proposed you know they don't have to
just
yes kind of look at this like centrifuge
and
kind of scratch their head and wonder
what the hell that thing is you know so
yeah
it's it's kind of like what um
what one of your um close friends here
alex
uh knessovic was introducing as you
introduced me to him and i got
introduced to his work in ophthalmology
he also has a very similar process where
the actual optometrists
do a significant amount of the upfront
work for the ophthalmologist to be able
to see the
client in a way that's more efficient so
as you pass
also the file over to the the fire
safety engineer
who has to review and provide their
feedback to the city
who then doesn't have to do the hyper
nuanced analysis of
the fire stuff because that was already
modularly taken care of
great yeah once again that reference to
the modular yeah
yeah which i i you know i don't we
didn't rip off it but
you know the line of thinking that we
have around it which we can do we can
kind of go down that now or we can
save it yeah i think so i think we have
so many things to also talk about
regarding like
consciousness and metaphysics the nature
of reality the nature of being
also maximizing human potential next
generation architectures all this kind
of stuff philosophy psychology
archetypes uh temperaments all these
types of things that we can dive into
more nuance on our
second convo that so that that'll be
another hour so
okay we'll do that um on wrapping on on
cannabis architecture stuff
um i mean
yeah the stuff we were talking about
regarding that the modularity of that uh
metal booth component of the c1d1 labs
that's kind of like the great gizmo
archetype that you were talking about
yeah
i'll give a quick kind of i you know i
think you and i are both philosophical
people
and though it's fun for me to talk
in some sense to talk really technical
and nitty-gritty i think i'm always
going to be most comfortable in the
philosophical space so
where this all kind of ties a bow on
this is is back to this idea of
modularity and
i kind of have a personal philosophy
around that idea
and
to first paint the picture like you you
before you brought up the shipping
container so
i'm going to kind of unpack this idea in
real time but there's this concept that
i like to call
form factor change so a lot of times
when you see
really grand leaps
in innovation and in technology and in
culture or when you have a form factor
change
and to me an example that could be the
shipping container
it could be the iphone it's this idea
that you kind of have this new
self-contained thing
in which you've collapsed certain uses
and efficiencies into like
a lot of the innovation you see is is
incremental right you already have the
form
you have this kind of you see this a lot
in architecture even like
it's been a long time since somebody
questioned the wall
like that we only tweak the wall we say
okay here's a hundred different
materials we can make the wall out of
but has anybody ever gone from first
principles and said
can we make something that does the same
thing a wall does philosophically
that isn't a wall and that's what i mean
by form factor so
the shipping container was really
powerful because if you understand the
history of how
shipping used to occur it literally was
it was this really intense enterprise
where you had this
you know large large set of employees at
every single
dock around the world these longshoremen
like just just
like there was longshoremen's unions it
was a whole
massive market and a massive
industry and there was no
standardization
meaning that you know every ship was
different go ahead i want to give the
name because it's so important
okay because you you brought this into
our consciousness we need to give the
name
keith tantlinger
keith tantalinger keith tantlinger
go look that up keith tantlinger because
that is such a profound
innovation in the great gizmo space that
we're unpacking
keith tantlinger all right please
continue now that we've given the name
it was really important for us to get
that name i agree look it up i think
that's innovation in the shipping
containers on barges
um ninety percent of all world trade
happens by c
nuts al and alan taught me that i did
not that was something i was unaware of
and that's when you hit the ball back
with keith tanlinger keith handling her
and i was like
blown by that modular component i love
that all right i don't remember where i
first heard about it too but
it was something that struck me because
it was one of those 10x moments so you
used to have this really kind of
haphazard
um on a shipping and loading process
happening across the world at every
single dock it was these longshoremen
that were you know literally lifting
individual crates
all different sizes like imagine a
really messy mover
you know nothing's kind of in
standardized boxes it's just
it's just really rough and tumble right
and it takes forever
we're taking like i you know i don't
want to say numbers because i don't know
enough to say numbers but
you know we were spending days upon days
to unload even small boats probably
um so think about our globalized economy
now where we
expect goods to be ping-ponged across
the earth
at such a rapid rate 30-minute drone
shipping
yeah yeah and that's perhaps that's even
the other iteration of this but
that would have never been possible with
this old version of you know
guys just pulling individual crates you
know little box little box by box like
the same way you'd
you know you you'd move in your house
that's just completely inefficient
and this it was this
what was brilliant about it was it was
this super concise super simple solution
that that's almost so deadly obvious
that you laughed to think that nobody
thought of it before
why don't we just create one box one big
box
that we kind of use as the base module
and then every other system
involved with the infrastructure of
delivering these
you know delivery and unloading and and
and shipping is all built around that
module right it's you know every crane
is pre-sized to be able to pick up a 40
by
8 shipping container 20 by 8 shipping
container you started with this module
and everything springs
out from that and the incredible level
of
efficiency that was delivered i mean
we're talking the gentleman that
invented this
became probably a billionaire yeah
because this just
i mean he just undercut the market right
this was like
it's exponential it wasn't a little bit
better such good optimism
elon musk's words you can't your new
product as an entrepreneur can't just be
a little bit better
it has to be orders of magnitude better
because the way humans work right we're
going to always default to the heinz
ketchups of the world
we're always going to default to the um
the coca-colas unless your cola is 10x
better
people aren't going to look at it it's
human psychology we go with what's
familiar unless it's way way way better
right people won't even notice yeah but
this guy changed the world
he's an unspoken hero yeah for sure yep
yep and i see this pattern acro i mean i
could go on forever it
it there's an element of this that's a
very kind of western and american way of
approaching things like how do we
create discrete solutions that can
almost be tacked on to solve a problem
like you saw that with an argument that
was made by one of my favorite
architectural
uh theorists a gentleman named rayner
banham which i would highly recommend
you you all look up
he's uh probably not very well known
outside of architecture
but he actually had quite a fascination
and a fetishization almost of los
angeles
he wrote a very iconic book called
los angeles the architecture of four
ecologies where he kind of distills the
different infrastructures of la
and how they kind of enabled the city um
he
analyzes the freeways the beaches the
suburbs
um it's been a while since i've read it
you know i can't speak to it too well
but
he wrote a shorter essay that was called
the great gizmo
and it analyzed this kind of like
american
um almost decentralized the american
tendency to derive decentralized
discrete solutions to problems you know
the archetypical um example that he used
was the boat
the uh the um the outboard motor that
used on a boat
like instead of having to just you know
come up with this custom thing for every
single boat where oh we gotta consider
like what's the whole width what's the
whole thickness
where's the mower gonna rest in the hole
like this little thing
this little solution like we're just
gonna build this box that you clip on
and it solves the problem and it works
with any boat and it creates mobility
you know um and i kind of see that with
the iphone too like this kind of
self-contained thing that solves all
these problems and kind of can be
deployed for anything like
it it can be a video um capture it can
be a phone
it could be an internet search but it's
all on this like little handheld it's
it's
instead of creating these kind of custom
one-off things to do
all these little things you create this
really you know poetic
solution that's all self-contained yes
um
love that yep and that's what i see in
the best designs it's kind of synthesis
yes but i love that yeah the
yeah um eo wilson wrote that
you know the world will be run by
synthesis
yeah i'm such a believer in that totally
and
you that's that's a huge perception
augmentation to be able to see the way
that you can
turn things into a module that is
so so
incredibly fruitful for optimization i
love that
and infinitely deployable you know
something that is irrespective of the
context in some ways gonna work you know
something that kind of
has this rugged almost libertarian
sensibility to it right like
you know i i the other example i think
we talked about before
we got on on live was about the covered
wagon perhaps is like an iteration of
this that it's
the covered wagon almost predated you
know there's this kind of
people drive around the country now and
campers and this kind of hippie vision
of you can go anywhere
live anywhere you know everything you
need can be put in a little
box and you can live a truly free
pioneering free-willing lifestyle but
the old version of that was you packed
up this
module of the covered wagon and that
brought you to the new
not the new world but the the the
western the the manifest destiny the
western
u.s you know you just packed that thing
up and it was a one-stop solution
to to take your life from boston to
reno nevada san francisco you know so i
think
you know it's there's something uniquely
entrepreneurial american libertarian
free thinking
about that those kind of solutions and
they're very there's a connection i
think to decentralization
that's happening now with currency all
that i think we're seeing that rebooted
again this kind of
strong interest in not having a
centralized mechanism
you know a train is way is the opposite
of a covered wagon right like you
have to have heavy infrastructure for
the train to run on
like there's a hierarchy of the engine
there's the
passenger cars there's the caboose like
you need all these
things you can't just buy just the
covered wagon
and hitch a horse to it and you know so
yeah yeah hmm
yeah there's yeah there's a lot of
nuance because there's also kind of like
this
centralization component also to the
iphone as well as much as right which is
kind of interesting so there's a
little like nuance there but yeah it's
not a perfect that
i think that one's not a perfect game
but even then there's kind of a
centralization and a sense component to
even the
like the boat motor or the the shipping
container in the sense of
it being kind of like patented as
the only uh solution for
the boat motor or for the shipping
container and then
everybody has to run through the
centralized entity on that
part of the train of the of execution
but at the same time this sort of great
gizmo
um decentralization is
very profoundly
seen through my first tennis ball back
to you when you were walking me through
the
keith tantlinger innovation was that
it so profoundly resonated with me
regarding data interoperability
yeah i'm glad you're bringing that
example up and that really that that hit
me like a ton of bricks
my mind just was racing after that it's
so smart let's tell us about that
just quick uh on this is that
the same way that and i write about this
in high level perception as well
that the same way that you see
the intercellular communication
happening between
two cells to be able to talk the same
way that
on the micro level on the meso level
between two humans being able to talk
or on the macro level between two
countries
being able to send goods to each other
via barges across the sea
yeah and if you can draw this kind of
multi-leveled
analogy between that you can begin
realizing also that
there are significant issues with data
interoperability
with the sort of way that
in just in the united states you can
take a domestic one with
google and apple and facebook and
amazon and twitter and uber and netflix
and
all these big giants microsoft because
their centralized data
is in a silo and there's no
intercommunication between them
interoperability of that data
yeah and if there was we could gain a
tremendous amount of profound
insight and and actually
not only like visualize our own kind of
synthesis of data which would be very
fruitful
but also kind of like pay into that
process
you know as an inclusive stakeholder of
our own
data that is being centralized to sort
of decentralize it
um become an inclusive stakeholder owner
of it
and for all of the unique insights
to emerge through a beautiful
visualization tool
and by the way so that was the domestic
example us has the same problem that
china does in that sense
china might be a little bit more porous
between companies like tencent and
alibaba and dji and stuff like that
might be a little more porous dd etc in
china
because of kind of just the the actual
fabric of the
interconnection between companies and
the state
that type of thing whereas we don't have
that so much
um and on a
on a planetary level so rather than the
domestic levels in the us and china on
the planetary level
that can be thought of like
like almost like the united nations is
like the meeting place of
200 cells that go
and meet at the united nations that then
have some sort of like an intercellular
communication that occurs
yeah to say something along the lines of
like
hey you know
congo right now is having um
issues with the amount of uh
deforestation that's occurring
and what because they want to become
more economically
they want to receive the economic fruits
and so
uh what we can do is instead of defor
like brazil with deforestation congo
with deforestation
instead of um having some of the
perverse incentives
around um the destruction of our
eco-planetary ecology
for the short-term gratification of
economic
growth what we can do is we can provide
a financial
incentive for places like brazil and the
congo
to preserve the rainforests
because um somewhere around
uh 30 percent of all of the planetary
photosynthesis that occurs that enables
us to take the 20 000 breaths
of oxygen that we take every single day
is occurring from the rain forest and 70
occurs from the photosynthesis from the
phytoplankton
it's profoundly important for us to keep
our
rainforests and so and there's a lot of
biodiversity that can be found there
that can also be uh kind of like what
happened with
a gfp and jellyfish or with channel
rhodopsin
in algae algae algae for
optogenetics or for other biotech
advancements there is a lot of
biodiversity that we can leverage to
understand
um where the next crispr cast 9 is and
things like that so
you definitely don't want to wipe out
biodiversity because there's a lot of
unique insights that we could
retain so congregating on a planetary
level the cells to be able to talk to
each other and create these
inclusive stakeholding data
interoperabilities
is super duper important and extremely
undervalued and is the future
of if we want to actually be able to
attain
star trek because i want star trek
everyone really wants star trek level
abundance
but right now it's like chimpanzees
throwing poop at each other's faces
on the planetary level and so you if you
imagine the planet earth as a single
cell
um if the usa is the mitochondria and
china is the ribosome
and saudi arabia is the uh the gogi
apparatus
and uh you have all these different
cellular components
they need to be able to talk to each
other in trust cellularly
intra right so inside of the actual cell
they need to be able to properly talk to
each other so the cell does not
pathologize
the same thing is true on the planetary
level if saudi arabia and russia
and the congo and brazil and china in
japan and the us
and germany uk don't talk to each other
efficiently
we will have planetary pathology occur
and that's sort of what we just
are seeing right now is a lot of great
success mixed with
a lot of pathology and the way to solve
that
is to increase our data interoperability
our communication between each other so
that we can inclusively stakehold
all of our flourishing towards that star
trek future that we all want
and as we said in high level perception
that is
the seed that is the nutrient of every
single
human getting the proper nourishment
that it needs
in order to flower and produce gifts
that's right that's the essence that
part that part
wow it's a very beautiful vision very
beautiful vision alan
and i think it stemmed from that right
that keith tantlinger
you know bit on you can't just know that
90 of all world trade happens by c
you also have to know that keith
tantlinger made this incredible modular
advancement that enabled exactly
uh and that is interoperability exactly
yeah and
analogously that that's the
inter-cellular inoperability
operability was that was that little
module that that's kind of the transfer
point between
port a and port b they can now
communicate with each other because they
have the standardized unit
the crane over there lifts a 20 by
eight and the crane over there also
lifts a 20 by eight so like the
crane in oakland and the crane in
singapore
exactly is the same style of crane
that's picking up the same
sort of style sized container and
imagine that it used to not be that
yeah it was every box was a different
size different sizes i think you said it
was like
in the moving truck you know in the
moving truck imagine that the chaos of
that right
but on the scale of global um shipping
and so this was the shipping container
thing was also
a uh a catalyst for
globalization in a global marketplace
you know without that we would not have
everything at our doorstep from amazon
you know whenever we need it
it was preceded all those other things
that we think
you know we kind of we i think some of
us because we
over emphasize or we you know we love
technology so much and it's really at
the forefront
tech tech in the sense of um software
that's kind of how we think about
everything but those innovations in the
physical world yes
that predated amazon if those wouldn't
happen and fell into place there could
have never been amazon there that's
right
that interoperability interoperability
but the part i think you you mentioned
in your last kind of breakdown of this
subject as well that i think we really
honed in on was
this idea of interoperability between
data packets
like can somebody come up with a
shipping container
for data for it for personal data so
that it it there can be
some sort of um transfer personal data
or you know kind of how a person is
using software their trends their habits
their
predilections can there be a module that
so that
um it can be shared between companies or
non-profits or governments
in a good way ideally i mean there has
to be of course some sort of ethical way
to do this but
right now any data information that
facebook has about us as far as i
understand there is not like backwards
compatibility with that data
um however that's mind or however it's
it's it's tabulated that data can't be
sent to the government or to
a non-profit and i i don't think they
can read that right
there's not it's it's like an operating
system difference like they're on
windows
metaphorically and then the other
company is on on on mac os
right there's not there isn't that form
factor
uh same yes yeah and i would love to
uh give a shout out because you're
speaking about exactly what we
interviewed we're both speaking about
the subject we
interviewed john battelle on the show
and he is literally currently right now
working on a machine portability
in data interoperability it's fantastic
so
it's a billion dollar idea in my opinion
yeah yeah yeah
and so he's doing that at columbia right
now
so i would highly recommend watching the
episode if that's
something you're passionate about with
john battelle
and i actually think it was called like
data architecture so that's very funny
that
this course got to this
within our episode about architecting
uh it's all really architecting
as we've um philosophically said many
times in our
last week together that architecting is
absolutely not limited to
houses and offices um but it's also
in in essence architecting is
the way that you on a macro
level can envision civilization design
yeah and that's my favorite way to
envision
both in the physical and in the
intangible world yeah yeah
it's the relationship between parts and
pieces you know yeah in any discipline
or in any kind of
field or pursuit you know like i think
a company has an architecture right like
what is the relationship between
hr and in marketing and the executive
team
you know those intangible are how do you
architect sure you know
how do you architect those relationships
yeah and that's another are they
hierarchical
are they yeah how do they yeah what is
the inner interoperability
yeah and what's the interoperability of
the communication blueprint and uh as
architecting is on the parts and pieces
i would this is going to lead us into
the next convo
that i would recommend also
as you do look at parts and pieces for
people to also look at the whole
that's right and i agree and as you look
at the whole
we're not talking about uh the whole
of you as a person or the whole of your
family or the whole of the
the company we're not talking about the
whole of the country
we're not even talking about the whole
of the planet
we're talking about the whole reality
the whole existence the physical and the
metaphysical
yeah yeah and so if you can
more frequently draw yourself
into that space of as has been termed
holism the more that you the more that
you sort of
bring yourself into that metaphysical
space
of of really feeling and experience
the whole of everything happening
simultaneously that's when you can
really begin to wander into some more
slowly
enlightening slowly
augmenting states of awareness and
consciousness
and so uh let's lead into that in our in
our next
there it is that was so fire
um guys thank you so much everyone thank
you
we love you thank you for tuning in this
was
so profoundly epic um yeah we had
a epic breakdown of architecting in
general
cannabis architecture the importance of
the city getting some uh
explosion proof modularity
it's a great that's a great band name oh
my god
explosion proof modularity wow um
yeah so that was epic um i highly
recommend anybody um
who's basically getting excited about
emerging market of cannabis and hemp
to uh
you know really kind of take the
perspective of what evan did in the
sense of like analyzing the landscape
and then getting in on the you know the
peter telling competitions for losers
get in on that
niche on that niche um and then the
other thing
the thing i always push when to riff off
what you were just saying
so i'm just cannabis adjacent at the end
of the day i'm trained my training and
my studies were in architecture i do
design you know that's really where my
core skill is
but what i tell anybody who's doing
something you know whatever it is in the
world if you're a
professional public speaker you're a
waiter or a driver
there's a potential way you can do that
in a cannabis
adjacent way the cannabis industry needs
every
they need accountants they need they
need every single
type of profession and type of worker
that you would find in every other
discipline or industry that's right but
you're if you do it specifically within
cannabis you're
you're hitching your thing you're
hitching your ride
to a really rocketing ship so that's
kind of my cell
right on that no matter what you do
there's a place for you in cannabis
right yeah that's interesting i
literally just imagine the
the rocket ship of the emerging market
taking off and you're and you're like
you're putting one of your the like
those like harnesses
just like clicking on and then like
rising yourself
up so this is very important especially
for um
those that have been underserved and
underprivileged in
um as they've been uh raised and
first this could be your moment this
could be your moment so um
yeah exactly so so grab the
reigns and and uh and and pursue
entrepreneurship here
so that's epic we had some also some
great breakdown with the great gizmo
philosophy there that was awesome so
keith tantlinger for those that
really again want to kind of dive into
that uh
data interoperability modularity i love
that
i mean that's it that's it folks um also
find the links in the bio below
you can find um evan bliss's
uh uh we'll put your linkedin profile
your
instagram account we'll put those down
there find those links below
also um studio bliss
will put some we'll put some uh info
there soon
that's right for people content some
content um
and then uh reach out to evan if you
want to
uh get more immersed in the space if
you're a potential client
uh hella this is your guy
who's doing the combinatorics of the
different cannabis architectures this is
your guy
and on in terms of
on behalf of simulation as you guys know
you can find all of our links in the bio
below
you know that we always recommend
supporting
the the the artists the entrepreneurs
the scientists the spiritual leaders in
your communities
and around the world support them and
help them grow
these are the people that are taking the
big risks these are the people that are
wanting to push the next code updates so
support them
become one yourself support them support
simulation all of our links are in the
bio below to support us
you can also find the link to my most
recent
uh my first book my most recent visual
synthesis called high level perception
you can find that down there
the physical copy of that book will be
available across all major platforms
uh before christmas so get excited about
that fantastic boom
and that
is all thank you again for your love
thank you for your support thank you for
watching the show we greatly appreciate
it we'd love to hear your thoughts on
the comments below on the episode
let us know what you're thinking and
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thanks folks
thanks for tuning in thanks alan thanks
evan so fire there it is
i love it l.a first episode in l.a wow
ah
maiden voyage
what more can i say welcome to l.a